so that's what's cool about you i [ __ ]
my pants today
tom segura did as well yeah yeah oh my
god
why did you [ __ ] your pants well tell
him what happened
well i had a doctor's appointment today
and he was nice enough to drive me there
and then somewhere along
by the beverly center it was like a
sudden attack it was like i have to [ __ ]
right now and so we pull
up right next to my in front of my
doctor's office first of all she doesn't
even know where the [ __ ]
the doctor's office is she's like this
it's a new one i hadn't been there polly
so
we parked and i was like you're not
gonna [ __ ] in the back seat so go inside
the um the office and ask to use their
bathroom but since it's kovid
they said no wow so um
i just walked away yeah i didn't even
help like all the homeless people that's
what i
was like please for the love of god do
not [ __ ] do not [ __ ]
in the car and i was like just [ __ ]
outside right in the gutter
yeah but he opted on la cienega are you
out of your [ __ ] mind
the busiest streets in america
you can pull over at like a lingerie
store on los cindy around the corner
people probably [ __ ] over there all the
time
yeah i would just i inside the car you
know what's great about your guys
relationship
is that it is such a real [ __ ] like
there's
there's no um uh what's the word you
guys
you guys are very um open about your
relationship because whenever anytime
i've been in a relationship i never
looked at my girlfriend
and being like yeah when i was [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] like tom segura and
this girl always talking about [ __ ]
too
hey you guys are like this is crazy
that's like when you're in dude yeah i'm
in you're like
[ __ ] like fall in yeah yeah we're a
little too far in yeah
but so she goes i just walked away she
she walks away she walks away
just down well like a [ __ ] bastard
typically in the past because i'm super
codependent i would always be the person
to try to find a solution
at this point i'm like you know what
there's nothing i can do if he's
dead set on [ __ ] in the back seat
i'm not going to fight him because he's
already
said that you act as if but i'm trying
to
i know but you act as if i have choices
you do
just anywhere but the car yeah just get
out because i have to drive 30 minutes
back home with you with now a big pile
of [ __ ]
there's definitely a difference between
[ __ ] in the car and pissing in the
car
yeah no [ __ ] no [ __ ] no [ __ ]
okay but this is how i know he's grown a
lot
in the last year oh because at all the
previous times he's just
bare-assed it right on the back seat but
this time around
he found uh an old trader joe's plastic
bag i don't know they're not plastic
the fancy ones which one paper bag the
fans no the fancy treasure oh my god my
trader joe's yeah
in the morning bag both of them the
reusable bag the reasonable
the nice one okay well the cloth one you
know i appreciate that that's how i know
he
yeah he had two in the back i don't even
know where they came from so where did
you wind up [ __ ]
in one of the fancy trader joe back here
prius
in the back of my prius and i i cupped
it right like this so i had both handles
like this
right so i had my both and i had my ass
like this
and i knew the target was in the right
spot yeah and then it was just like a
fudge factory
and then the other trader joe's back
wipe your ass with it the other trader
joe's back i usually it's caught me like
cotton or bags
yeah yeah so i wiped it i put the other
one in there
right yeah and i left it in front of the
the the office that didn't let me use it
that's perfect that's the comedic way
yeah that's good
dude i one time yo i one time [ __ ] in a
[ __ ] trash can in a manager's office
at a comedy club in new mexico
really yeah because there was no no for
real i was about
i was it was back in the wee's days it
was crazy
yeah it was a comedy club in new mexico
and um and there was two shows and you
know the comedy clubs don't have
um bathrooms in the office or there's no
green room
so the only bathroom you can use is what
where the patrons are oh yeah yeah
really there's so many clubs like that i
can't even
yeah so you're sitting there in the
[ __ ] manager's
office yeah and i'm like going [ __ ] i
got to take a [ __ ]
yeah and i'm like [ __ ] it yo i got the
truck here she give me that trash can
right there
no it looked like it yeah it looked like
this trash can
yeah yeah yeah
this is probably the same trash can but
can you see it yeah yeah
so i got a a bag trash it you know like
the hefty bag thing or whatever
yeah and i just lean i just [ __ ] in it
yeah and i tied it really tight
and then when i was on stage i guess the
owner found out that i did it
because i guess it smelled but i had
tightened i tightened it really tight
and i didn't think so
yeah and then he found out and then when
i try to book myself the next year he's
like no and i got
blackballed from that club for [ __ ]
in the trash can
and i said what you're gonna say is like
where am i supposed to [ __ ]
yeah where the [ __ ] i know that's where
we think but he didn't think that way
yeah people people don't realize you
know
at least for me right i have all the
same
equipment as you guys do in terms of
bodily function yeah right
i have little legs you know that work
vessels strong
i mean fair thank you you're strong
thank you i have a stink third muscle
right for some reason sometimes because
maybe because of my diet
right that i have these sudden urges and
i cannot stop it
it's like it's coming right and there's
almost nothing better
feeling wise than taking a [ __ ]
especially if you really have to [ __ ] oh
it's the best
it's nothing bad it goes coming and then
[ __ ]
speaking of taking a [ __ ] my friend
chris katan oh yeah yeah he wants you to
he wants to be on your show oh i know he
does
i know he does i'm just i love chris
and two weeks ago i called him and he
didn't call me back and there